In this populist moment, conservatives
should champion and renew their basic
values, principles, and priorities, and the
economic policies that flow from them.
These commitments advance a particular
vision of society in which free markets
reward individual initiative, public
policy advances opportunity, and energy
and dynamism characterize our economic
lives. It's a society that demands
personal responsibility, self-reliance,
and self-discipline, but also recognizes
human imperfection and uncertainty, and
therefore allows no one to fall too far.
And it's a society in which mediating
institutions, most especially the family,
are strong and vibrant. Specifically,
conservatives should not retreat from
their long-held policy views on the
importance of economic growth, free trade,
entitlement reform, and friendliness to
immigrants. But conservatives should also
update their agenda to address low rates
of workforce participation, sluggish wage
growth, a health care sector in need of
reform, failing schools, and much more.
Conservatives should remember that
limited, energetic government has a
positive role to play in a properly
ordered society, empowering individuals
to earn their own success, to realize
their potential, and lead lives of dignity.
How do you think economic
policy should respond to populism? Let us
know in your comments. Also, let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.